pour répondre à cette situation de
nouvelles mesures s'appliqueront donc à
partir de samedi à l'issue de la même
manière d'une concertation avec le
préfet et les élus locaux ces mesures
j'ai conscience qu'elles sont difficiles
mais elles sont et nous en sommes
convaincus
nécessaires il s'agit tout d'abord de la
fermeture totale des bars et des
restaurants de la fermeture de
l'ensemble des établissements recevant
publ sauf s'il existe un protocole
sanitaire strict déjà mis en place à ce
titre les lieux culturels comme les
théâtres les musées les cinémas ont
disposent de protocoles sanitaires
strict et ne sont donc pas concernés par
les mesures de fermeture et par ailleurs
nous incitons au maximum au télétravail
pour l'ensemble des activités pour
lesquelles c'est possible dans Cees
territoire ces dispositions elles sont
temporaires elles concent donc des zones
d'alerte renforcées des zones d'alerte
maximales elles sont malheureusement les
seules de nature à limiter les
contaminations l'objectif est qu'elle ne
dure pas plus de 2 semaines le temps de
freiner la propagation du virus